okay okay besser als ob fünf man ihr zu
folgen
lawley sie fünf spieler sechs kids und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
hacker show wie immer zeige ich euch
heute die 5 witzigsten hacker der
letzten woche und wir wollen kleine
special wir legen direkt los ihr wisst
ja wenn ihr dabei sein wollt wie immer
video um gelistet hochladen und mit den
link zum gelisteten video per youtube em
schicken dann habt ihr gute chancen weit
zu sein ich sehe alle einsendungen okay
gut platz nummer es ist die platz eins
es lief fast 5 es gar keinen platz aber
ich wollte das unbedingt mit rein nehmen
und zwar von vegas diese einsendung und
ja wir schauen mal rein sieht es darauf
jedenfalls laura da sieht man die kiste
und tötet ihn eiskalt nochmal bis heute
hat jemand jahre seines lebens
reingesteckt dieses video so gut diese
qualität einfach und da sieht man wieder
die klare alter ganz klar auch da oben
sieht man den namen aktuelle web sg 7
also ist es länder die map angezeigt
wird und das ist ne box mit killer also
wenn ihr welche servers eigentlich wenn
ihr wisst welche services treffen und in
die kommentare
falls sap ist ein hilfsmittel aerox bei
100 kilo sg sieben und ab zu platz fünf
platz 5 stammt von mcp heißt slowmotion
hecke auf timo ja slow motion slow
motion
ich habe keine ahnung vom aussehen soll
wie schon rein er fällt auch schon mal
mega langsam
er bewegt sich wenig dafür so weiter ich
meine ich verstehe warum 1 petek benutzt
um besser zu sein aber in slow motion
eck machte georg kleine klar natürlich
auch aber what the hell was ist das denn
in slow motion heck den halt der welt
auf jeden fall gebraucht den hat die
welt gebraucht in slow motion damit ihr
jetzt noch schlechter sein könnte ab
jetzt zu kaufen auf itsax.de ayala
deutschland
nein das ging natürlich werde ich
niemals sie mal sex verkaufen weil das
ist doch jetzt schon gesagt dass sie
keine hacks kaufen sollte ist es blöd
ist sparte taschengeld leber oder kauft
durch den zwei bühnen
das ist besser auf jeden fall habe ich
hier mister slow motion wie er leibt und
lebt
spaziert durch die gegen klarer ist am
start natürlich also ich hab auch gar
keine ahnung was das sein soll ist die
slow motion experten da draußen was ist
es slow motion heck oder norddeutschen
beck jetzt stirbt einfach hat sich
gelohnt zu hacken
hätte ich meine hektar einen keinen
unfairen vorteil bietet folge stand timo
dazu seien die modelle total verseucht
was die tags angeht und geraten die
kratzten klassen mit einer range von
zehn blöcken oder so aber das ist schön
blöd immer noch weißen hacker ist schön
platz 4 stammt von leons let's play und
er hat das video ganz klassisch enjoy
the sky genannt pokémon wir gucken aus
der fantast moment mal trifft es ganz
gut 8 x ja klaro alter haben fand man
dass diese telepool ich habe aufgepasst
jetzt setzt die kommentare geschrieben
es kann dieser teleporter sein denn die
tiere so hoch und dann rücken die basic
das kann dieser teleporter sei aber doch
nicht so oder ach nee wisst ihr was ich
bin also dem teleporter zurück das sieht
ein bisschen zu strangers darum gerade
weiß man erst mal schwert kaufen wichtig
wichtig wenn einer in die wolken schießt
und dann runter gesehen kommt man davon
ausgeht dass es im heck ist dann erstmal
ein holzschwert kaufen weil er bestimmt
auch keine kilowatt und jetzt das
material
ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht leute ich
weiß nicht ist das ein hack oder ist das
also erschafft report also auf jeden
fall glaube ich nicht dass er da oben
sein sollte auf diesem flugzeug das sie
mir nicht nach ort aus dem man mit
legalen mitteln erreichen kann ich sag's
ein hacker warm reporting auf kompass
alles klar kommt sagte hacker was gibt
es für hacker für hacker gibt es ein
kräftiges angeles ke
okay leute platz drei standen von nick
alpha hd und wurde leicht auf einer
kartoffel aufgenommen aber unterstützt
die deutsche landwirtschaft deswegen
möchte ich auch in dem ich auch videos
rein nehme die auf kartoffeln
aufgenommen werden den absatz von
kartoffel unterstützen
aber bitte in zukunft leute nicht nicht
144 p und nicht schwarze balken übrigens
guck mal hier
das habe ich jetzt mal bekommen von
meiner mutter das ist ein büroklammern
entfernen
das sieht ein bisschen aus wie das a von
assassin's creed oder ein bisschen
fantasie und wäre gesagt dass man damit
nicht alle leute umlegen kann stress
mache alles da nick alpha hd dass du
bist ja ich glaube man sollte eigentlich
nichts für mich sagt schon jetzt muss
ich sagen ich hätte natürlich war das
alles andere als fit ist wieder oder
natur und stirbt möglich mehr kartoffeln
auf neben mich mehr auf kartoffeln
neben bitte nicht auf kartoffeln auf ja
ja ja leute sollte man eigentlich nicht
machen aber jetzt wird es in die andere
richtung und 32 es stimmt soweit von
platz zwei springen weil dazu platz
nummer 2 stammt von officer panda road
to 0.5 kassab herz und nennt das video
ein wettrennen zwischen hacker
ausrufezeichen 7 hacker in einer runde
also ich muss sagen zwei hatte ich schon
mal eine runde ja auch schon mal 34 war
glaube ich das maximum
aber das wort [ __ ] 7 also schauen wieder
einsehen dass eventuellen partien die
gerade nicht live spielen weil die der
luft sind wo sie wahrscheinlich nicht
sein sollten aber okay okay alles klappt
es mal kurz mal weg so schön hoch runter
wichtig sehr wichtig sehr wichtig ok
alles klar damals kandidat nummer eins
und bevor ich es vergesse dafür
natürlich ein ganz klassisches
ok alles ja ja als ob kein zweiter für
die sinne durch verfolgen fans alter
junge junge um junges und direkt auch
jetzt sehe ich erst ja wie sich
verfolgen ist ja wie quilitzsch alter
etwas gar dem eis kann nicht gesehen
kommentiert fliegen sie durch die gegend
das ist echt wie kretschmann mach du
scheiße man dieser server ist so krank
verseucht pass auf jetzt nur noch eine
note erhält auch alles klar
super noch fragen dann platz eins platz
eins stammt von x6 koops und heißt
hacker strecke report ok dann checke
nochmal rein sieht danach job liga
austria blick auf den weg kommen wollen
alles klar da haben auch schon unsere
tatverdächtigen alles klar hat dirt
jumper claudia schweda palast alle weg
junge jetzt schätze den vier typen und
jetzt da hat er einen start im technisch
einfach alle weg laufen alle laufen weg
wurde das mega viele medias darf
unterwegs hobbyfischer okay jetzt kommt
ein premium spieler sehr schön
vorbildlich premium spieler als premium
spieler musst du mit gutem beispiel
vorangehen es leid da durch die gegend
und jetzt alle gegen hacker ja wohl
junge die sie zu viert auf ihn drauf
gehen
das alter so muss das sein
auf geht's für den drecksack jetzt ganz
okay okay das ist als ob fünfmal nähe zu
folgen
lawley sie fünf spieler und sie haben
mich gekillt und es raus alter schwede
dafür gibt es eine sitzung im chat
angeles ke danny ecker wurde android von
fünf man gleichzeitig group enjoy enjoy
auch mit euren friends in der group
group n joy der neue trend gerade wir
schon mal hier hin darauf der wechsel
auf der weg dann öfter weg und dann zack
habe sie getötet so muss es sein leute
wenn ihr mitbekommt dass einer unter
euren freunden
fact dann gesammelt euch eure kollegen
und tötet ihn zusammen ja ich weiß dass
es irgendwie schön zu sehen wie die
leute so zusammen stehen so alle spieler
stehen zusammen und jason zusammen denn
hacker das wie so eine hexenjagd ich so
auf mit der ausnahme dessen dass die
hexen keine hacker waren vielleicht auch
gar nicht böse aber hier schnappen sie
sich hin und sagt bohm sehr schön leute
das ist ein schönes zeichen dass unser
platz eins für diese woche und man sich
gefallen würde ich mich über den daumen
nach oben freund wie immer wieder ganz
ganz ganz viele einsendungen im laufe
der woche das wasser wald von mir
ich danke euch fürs zuschauen bis zum
nächsten mal und